i love me a good celebration of nick
cage we're going to talk about that
celebration first i want to give some
love to the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by nordvpn
nordvpn's a vpn service that looks to
help you navigate this digital
wonderland slash digital minefield
called the internet more safely and they
have a myriad of services services
ranging from protection to convenience
nordvpn has released threat protection
feature which blocks malware scans
downloaded files for viruses but it also
allows you to change your virtual
location with one click allowing you to
watch content that might not be
available in the region or country
you're currently located it's like
everything is truly everywhere all at
once and when such a movie comes to a
streaming service you can watch it even
if it's not innately available in your
country just do them apart plus nord has
a 30 day money back guarantee which is a
solid piece of mind so click the link
below go to nordvpn.com
john's get yourself a two-year plan with
a huge discount plus one additional
month for free and thank you once again
to nordvpn for sponsoring this video i
do appreciate it and now
okay let's run
so the unbearable weight of massive
talent one of my anticipated movies of
2022 the movie stars nicholas cage
playing nicolas gate he's kind of down
on his luck he needs some money because
some of the projects he's picked lately
which right there like that is
confidence to me this movie is nic cage
confidence in a bottle not a lot of
actors can play a caricatured version of
themselves and not take themselves so
seriously how many people can take the
meme ability and some of the online
we'll call it [ __ ] talk about some of
the choices in their career and they'll
be like yeah we'll use that as a jumping
off point you know we'll get the plot
going in a movie where i play myself
that's cool so he gets the invite to get
paid a million dollars to hang out with
a super rich super fan played by pedro
pascal the cia gets win to this and
they're like oh that's a really
dangerous person so you're gonna spy on
him for us it is funny that the premise
of this movie did remind me of it's like
the movie the interview but starring
nicholas gage so it's a nick cage
celebration movie slash buddy comedy
slash spy comedy so many things in this
movie work because this movie does have
premise kevlar i call it where it's it's
nicholas cage playing nicolas cage in a
movie that celebrates nicolas cage
screwing that up would take a massive
amount of work one could call it talent
if they screwed this up i would almost
christ sabotage luckily they don't we
all love nic cage early coveted lockdown
one of the things i did is i reviewed
the nic cage holy trinity that would be
the father son and holy spirit and it
was amazing it was a good time that's
one of those string of reviews where i
was like
i'm proud of that and from there you
have all the movie references and movie
love you want some are obvious it's like
oh yeah we all love that some are deep
cuts man that captain corelli's mandolin
reference i was like that's that's in
the weeds right there which made it
better who am i kidding the chemistry
between pedro pascal and nicholas cage's
on point the support cast in this movie
all do their part really well but they
never eclipse the nick cage pedro pascal
dynamic the movie is quite literally on
their shoulders at a point in this movie
the nicholas cage pedro pascal dynamic
the friendship is so good you just kind
of don't care that this guy is
supposedly dangerous or you forget it
doesn't matter you just kind of fall
into it as for we'll call it the
celebration of nick cage angle i had so
much fun with that because that's who
wouldn't it's nick cage man is he crazy
nick cage
sometimes is he memeable
sometimes but is he also a talented
dramatic actor
[ __ ] yeah he is the movie has fun with
that he talks to this imaginary version
of himself called nikki whom we've seen
in interviews i will say the last act of
this movie becomes
essentially an action movie which is in
line with the nicholas cage celebration
they do a good job at tying it into that
the movie is also a very self-aware
movie in general so it's very aware that
it's going to that place and it
addresses that it's going to that place
but i gotta be honest the action movie
element that is the last act of this
movie was never as much fun as the first
two acts of this movie seeing nicholas
cage play this lovable yet down on his
luck caricatured self-centered version
of himself pedro pascal's character just
freaking out like fanboying that this
person's even hanging out with him the
two of them going on adventures
including but not limited to an lsd trip
like it was that was the most fun i had
with this movie in the end the
unbearable weight of massive talent is
at its peak at its strongest when it's
the nic cage celebration that it
promises to be and as much as that
celebration of him was fun to watch i
love the fact that it's seen through the
friendship of these two guys i never had
those laugh out loud deep gut laugh
moments but this movie had moments of
constant chuckling i just it's more
comedic appreciation i guess you call it
that it's more like you know like the
audience will give that nod of approval
like i approve of that reference you can
have things for us like i feel like i've
seen that in movies before but have you
seen it with the celebration of nick
cage as nick cage playing nick cage i
think not so you're like oh yeah it
feels new and if news not the word just
[ __ ] awesome is and actually side
note i love the fact that it does
briefly address the difference between
how an actor sees the work he does and
how fans do how fans have a personal
relationship with the work and the
actors a lot of times are like yeah i
love that movie
it paid bills just fine and i appreciate
that it's just this real thing that
people don't address but the movie
wrapped up with me having a good time
more than a good time a great time a
time worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray all right so the unbearable
weight of massive talent have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you